president Trump's decision to withdraw
US troops from northern Syria not only
opened the door to turkeys attack on
America's Kurdish allies it also created
a major power vacuum David Martin is at
the Pentagon David what does this mean
exactly for US interest in the region
well the US military is calling off what
it was a five-year campaign against Isis
and it's only mission now is to get out
of Syria as quickly and as safely as
possible and defense secretary mark
espera has warned American troops will
defend themselves meaning shoot back if
they feel threatened the decision to
withdraw some 1,000 troops came as
Turkish forces move deeper into Syria
than US officials expected we have
American forces likely caught between
two opposing advancing armies and it's a
very untenable situation the president
made the decision Saturday night and
defense secretary Mark Esper revealed
it's Sunday on Face the Nation with
Margaret Brennan he directed that we
began a deliberate withdrawal of forces
from northern Syria the decision was
also motivated by the expected and now
announced deal between the Kurds and the
Syrian government backed by Russia it
sounds a lot like they were being left
to be slaughtered so what choice were
they left other than to find someone
else to protect look at this the the
Kurds have been very good partners in
the D Isis campaign they were very good
fighters on the battlefield
we obviously enabled that as well but at
the same time we didn't sign up to fight
the Turks on their behalf meanwhile
Treasury secretary Steve minuchin and
top national security officials gathered
at the White House Sunday to discuss
possible sanctions against Turkey these
sanctions could be starting small they
could be maximum pressure which would
destroy the Turkish economy but critics
said sanctions would be too little too
late I don't know what this
administration is waiting for all
they're doing is talking what people are
being killed even Republican lawmakers
agree I think it is not necessarily
going to prevent turkey from doing what
they're doing this has been Turkey's
dream for a long time
and the president basically gave the
green light to do it the Pentagon has
plans for getting all US troops
within fifteen to thirty days but those
plans were drawn up before events
started spiraling out of control in
northeastern Syria Gail
alright David thank you